[Music]
Uh, yes, AI and a case study on the New
York Times connections, which is um the
team that I work on is our games team
and I work on our popular games. Um, if
anyone's uh heard of Connections before
or played Connections um or not, since
some people might have. So, um again, a
little bit about me, a game developer at
the times. I worked previously in media
for most of my career. Um and uh I have
a background in machine learning, mobile
development, and data science. So, the
majority of this talk is going to
probably involve a little bit of all of
those. So caveats about what you're
about to see and I'll get through as
much of it as I can because it's some of
it's a little bit dense but this is my
own independent research and
experimentation. Um it's not based on
our internal research. We do have
internal research and just need to
clarify that separation. Um the results
of this work are preliminary and subject
to refinement uh with additional
experimentation.
And the purpose of this work is
investigating investigatory not
authoritative. So it's mostly me trying
to kind of look into the realm of uh AI
problem solving in the game space
through our games and it's mostly like a
fun exercise. Um there does exist third
party research in AI as it resolves as
it relates to solving connections and
other games but and that's an
inspiration here for this project but
the processes and everything that I'm
describing here I did on my own with my
own research. So, um, for those of you
who are not familiar with the game,
Connections was launched by the New York
Times in, uh, June of 2023 into beta and
officially released in August of 2023 to
the greater world. Uh, the game is
edited by Waloo, who's a awesome editor
at the times that I work with um on
games and she creates the puzzles for
uh, connections. Um, it quickly became
one of the New York Times most played
games, second only to Wordle with
hundreds of millions of plays within its
first year. And um just to mention all
the connections, puzzles and game
itself, game the game mechanics and the
programming etc are humanmade now and
forever. So um all of our properties
fall into that category. So the game is
on the right in case um you have your
mobile apps want to download it. So how
connections works uh each so you have a
daily puzzle and each puzzle provides 16
words to be grouped. The visualization
on the right is kind of demonstrating
play. The goal is to form four groups of
words of four groups of four related
words. Uh each word belongs only to one
group. No overlaps and players can make
up to four incorrect guesses before
losing. So um you can see that uh as the
game finishes this particular situation,
the person has won the game. So this is
where the AI and data science and etc
start to come into play. There's a
difficulty structure to connections. So
people who play the game probably know
that the easiest category is yellow
where yellow is like the most obvious
when you actually solve the game the
most obvious connections are within the
yellow category. Green is the slightly
less obvious connections where you have
to kind of stretch a little to think but
once you get those it's kind of like oh
okay this is kind of obvious um why how
these things are related. Uh the blue
category is trickier themes where you
have things like sayings, um idiomatic,
lexical or trivia based themes. And then
purple is the infamous purple for those
of who you think of the game as a
difficult game. Uh is the category that
usually trips up most people from a
perfect win. And that's because there's
a a concept of decoy overlap misleads
that are associated with the purple
category.
Um so why is it an interesting game uh
via via AI analysis and standards? So it
uh can actually challenge AI's ability
to abstractly reason. And now at some
point in time we all believe that LLMs
can do absolutely everything. Um and
some people think that's true. But uh
one thing that Connections has done
throughout the course of its time period
is actually challenged LLMs to um
actually have a 100% solve rate. Um the
game's intentional decoys tests whether
AI can over avoid overfitting or
superficial similarities. Um each
solution requires clean and explainable
well aligned with AI transparency. So
like for example if you want to figure
out how AI reasoned through a game. This
is an actual good like process because
you do need some sort of reasoning and
perhaps abstract reasoning to solve like
the difficult or purple category and you
have get to see how AI thinks about
that. Um there's fixed input solutions
make it a reproducible and scalable test
bed. So one of the interesting things
that I like about this game particularly
is because it is a could be a potential
benchmarking tool and people have uses
as such to test the capabilities of AI
and since the puzzles are the same and
playable you can repeat this process and
this is just me entering the puzzle in
Chad GPT and Chad GPT giving the wrong
solution. This is sort of like um unfair
comparison because this is the 40 model.
the higher models do give better
reasoning, but that's not exactly uh
I'll go into that a little later if I
get the time. Um, and so how do humans
solve connections? Uh, there's the
concept of system one versus system two
thinking. Uh, I'm guessing many people
might be familiar with this concept. It
uh came out in uh the n the '9s. And um
it's so system one thinking is when
you're trying to intuitit relationships
very fast. when you see two things that
are obviously part of the same category,
you don't have to think so much. Your
your brain sort of makes that automatic
judgment. Um, system two, which is slow
and deliberate thinking, is where you
have like the sort of deep kind of
reasoning which you need to perform. And
that's where you're like, "Oh, I'm
struggling. I don't know if this belongs
to one or two. Let me use my knowledge
base." Um and then in order to solve the
games uh uh most effectively most people
use a high strategy where they've used
both the fast intuitive thinking and
then the slow deep thinking. And that's
what takes a lot of time in the actual
playing of the game. And then you can
suffer from canonical failures like
system one failures. You you thought it
looked obvious but you messed up because
it wasn't actually obvious. Stuff
belonged to a different category or
system two thinking where you're like I
thought too deeply about this but it was
actually the obvious one. And so, you
know, you overthought that one. So,
that's one of the fun parts of the game
if you think that's fun. Um, so
connection studies and benchmarks do
exist. There's several benchmarks uh for
solving connections with the later
models that are come out that have come
out. They're not by us. They're
thirdparty benchmarks, but they do
demonstrate progressive capability of
LLMs to uh solve the game, but it's
still not perfect. And as I mentioned
before, there are caveats to that
solvability.
So there's now I'm going into the like
deeper part and I'm going to see how far
I get through the rest of this because
this is where my AI analysis goes into
play. So um if this mathematics this is
your chances of winning the game if
you're guessing randomly right if you
use no intuition whatsoever. So um if
you're totally randomly guessing you
have uh if you have the complete initial
board you have about a 0% chance of
winning. Then the mathematics or
combinatorics of the connections board
uh indicate that after maybe if you get
one category right and you still need to
randomly guess through the next three
you have about a one in 5,000 one in
6,000 chance of winning which is tiny
but it's you know you could maybe do it
I don't know and then um most people get
stuck on the third and fourth category
where it's like oh I don't know like I
got two and now all these words how do
they relate to each other? So, if you're
like screw it, I'm going to guess
randomly. Uh, then you have a one in 35%
chance. One in 35 chance of winning or
about% chance. And that means that okay,
well, you're doing pretty good, I think.
Um, now the graph coloring problem.
We're going to go into a little bit of
CS. Uh, who's familiar with the graph
coloring problem? Okay, great. We have
CS people here. Yes. So, graph coloring
involves assigning colors to vertices of
a graph. The graph is the structure on
the right, which is basically a bunch of
nodes and edges. um there's some number
associated with the graph. Not going to
get too deep into that, but that I'm
doing that chromatic number is
important. Um and when you want to solve
a graph coloring problem, you use
algorithms that are popularly known,
backtracking, greedy coloring. And the
graph coloring problem just for interest
has um applications in all kinds of
areas outside of um you know just
science, scheduling, frequency
assignment, wireless networks and in
connections. that you can model
connections as a graph coloring an
augmented graph coloring problem. So
this is a connection solver that I built
on the right that a bunch of puzzles and
attempts to organize them into graph
coloring um groups. So each of the words
16 words and connections can be a vertex
in this graph. There hidden categories
that we already went over. They're
colorcoded. And the goal is to color
each word node with one of the four
categories such that all four words
belong to a specific category receive
the same color. And then the edge is the
strength of the connection that it's
thought of to exist between words. So
that is basically how related they are
is the edge. So the reason why that's
important is because that creates the
search space for an algorithm or an AI
to actually you know play the game
effectively um or solve the game
effectively. Without that it's falling
into the random range of gra of sorting
words and it becomes much more
difficult. So we have this idea of
semantic similarity. It's not enough. I
I wish I I've renamed it semantic
similarity is not all you need if you
get the transformer joke. Um so this is
like it's hard to see here but there's a
tree of word relationships between
different words. For example, anagrams
are related uh could be a a type of
category called orthography of words. So
um you know that could be an entire
category. morphology meaning things like
that have the same uh suffix like
something like kingdom fifom or
connectedness um things like that. Then
you have other semantic relationships
that are not so obvious which are could
be things like encyclopedic
relationships like for example globe
mirror post and sun are all part of the
newspaper category and then you have
things like associative relationships
things that are red or things that are
green right strawberry rose Mars etc.
And so again um the most I just going
back to this policy things that can like
for example what a mole can be an animal
birthark spy or unit uh that is where
the connections actually just for
interest sake is the most complicated
for most AIs and people because that's
the the poly multiple meaning section is
where on a base level people get tripped
up any intelligence can get tripped up.
So you have this concept of relational
alignment. So relational alignment is if
you can create a metric that associates
two words together, you can have a
relational alignment score. So there's
different metrics that are associated
with a relational alignment. And so I
created this heat map simulation on the
right which can pick different metrics
and show how based on the metric
calculations which I'm not showing here
that these two things are that these um
the two words from a large category are
related. Now um the bu story I'm
building up is that relational alignment
between puzzles uh can help you
determine on a computational way whether
a puzzle is easy or whether it's hard.
So this is for example from an easy
puzzle years ago that was uh done versus
a hard puzzle. And this is like um
people have described this as the solve
rate is 19% for the hard puzzle but like
70 something for the easier puzzle. And
you can see that there's a a rough
overarching coherence or relational
alignment score differential between
easy and hard. So that differential lets
you understand there's a computational
process which you can apply. So you can
see that time variant relational
alignment scores can go across
categories and time. So puzzles are
easy, puzzles are hard and you see some
sort of time variant metric which you
know you can you can com you can compute
this and you can draw a graph over time.
I'm not sure what happened here on 1212.
I think oh we had a broken puzzle that
day so it was zero. Um but the idea is
that you can see that there could be
patterns established from this um
alignment score that you compute. Now if
it was that easy that would be great but
it's not actually that easy because as
we have multiple different semantic
relationships we have multiple
relational alignment scores. So
basically uh two words can be related in
multiple ways and they can have
different scores across different
categories. So some can be semantically
or morphologically more strongly related
than they are um for example um
categorically or encyclopedically
related. But uh the idea is that you can
create sort of this radar chart which
lets you kind of map out some sort of
diagram or surface which you can analyze
to see how the uh semantic space of the
word across different categories looks.
That means you have yet another
dimension to analyze how your AI can
analyze how um to solve a puzzle or your
AI or solver or you yourself if you want
to think about like this stuff deep more
deeply using your um reasoning. So
multi-dimensional uh relational
alignment distribution was part of the
things that I was kind of looking at. So
I basically another component of the
system I built was the semantic
distribution evaluation framework where
I taking a bunch of our puzzles and then
I'm building this category categorical
distribution over time where you can see
on the lower right it's hard maybe to
see a little bit but there's the
different categories like hypernomy
morphology orthography things I talked
about and the distribution of categories
for um the connections puzzles over time
and so you can see I'm counting like
which categories over the days fall into
which um of these buckets with these
dots on this right and I can build a
sort of like histogram or count of this
association and so you can look at
trends and then you can use that data uh
that trend data. So now here what it
gets a little bit more involved um the
graph uh coloring approximation is a
search space reduction uh process but
then you get to the more complicated
idea of graph clustering. Once you add
the semantic relationships into the
actual uh formulation um you actually
start to build multi-dimensional or
hyperraphs. And this is just a
three-dimensional hyperraph. But if you
have multiple semantic relationships,
you actually have multi-dimensional
hyperraphs. And this is kind of just a
demonstration of how the hyperraph
converges in three dimensions. Meaning
that if you have all these semantic
relationships, you're going to have
these uh intercluster strengths between
uh different nodes and different
categories. But you also have the
intracluster strength which shows you
how strong the relationships are within
the clusters that form due to the
algorithm you're using. That's important
because the graph this graph gives you
more dimensionality and again will is a
more computational way of using AI to
solve this uh problem or any again
solver to solve the problem.
Um so how do you build these semantic
graphs? You can use different types of
lexical databases or lexical um
constructors. For example, word net,
concept net, and other word embeddings
can be used to construct these
relationships. And so this is a a flat
example of a 2D graph of one puzzle
where you see relationships between like
different words like for example, two
words co- occur together, a mouse hunts
a cat, a dog is related to a cat, a cat
is capable of play, a cat is used for
pet. And you can see the complex
dimensionality of these conceptual
semantic graphs as derived from word
net, concept net, and word embeddings
allows you even more space. So we're
increasing the intelligence here. You
see, I'm not just doing a reasoning
model or dumbly putting into an LLM. I'm
actually trying to increase this
intelligence space like procedurally so
that you can have a trackable and
explainable way. You know, explainable
AI, that's what I'm all about. This is
part of that. So um to get to the actual
model which does that anyone familiar
with graph neural networks? Okay. So if
you've used GNN's uh before that that
that's the primary since it's a
geometric problem in multi-pace you well
I the primary pro solver that I'm using
is a is a graph convolutional neural
network which allows you to kind of
create take in a graph as an input and
then put like candidate subgraphs that
could be solutions as outputs. This is
one part of the problem. It's part of a
two-part problem where I'm using the
graph the reinforcement learning system.
So once we have the graph neural network
that's actually outputting candidate
graphs, you have edge weights and node
weights that are being optimized and
then you find out which graph like fits
into the candidate solutions. Then you
can track the actual structure of the
graph which is just cluster morphology
or like how the graph looks. The next
visualization, this is the system
diagram. Not going to go into it. It's a
lot. But um I'll just say it's the
combination of aman learning agents with
uh a graph a graph based system for um
actually with the graph neural network
for kind of isolating how what candidate
graphs you have. And so this is I'm
almost out of time, but I'll just say
that this is kind of like how the
visualization looks in threespace. Once
your um semantic graphs are uh once your
semantic graphs are constructed, your
graph candidates and the reinforcement
learning system is kind of the
appropriate way to kind of navigate
these subclusters. And you can't
actually see the cluster points here
because the visualization wasn't super
great, but the actual output is kind of
like, okay, now this this traversal is
allowed to exist. So again um after all
this stuff the solvability rate from
before to after for a short a small
subset of hard puzzle puzzles increases
somewhat reasonably but now again this
is a work in progress and I tried this
against a few puzzles before and after
and now the idea is to extend this and
like make it more involved for even more
puzzles and then get to game
development. So why do all this or well
our LLMs are great at a bunch of stuff
but you know they can often make you
know their own mistakes. LLMs often are
trained on internet data and the puzzle
solutions are available on the internet.
So, who knows if they're just pulling
the solutions from the internet. That's
one thing that bothered me about uh LLM
solving these problems. And so, and
that's LLM solutions are still a black
box. And so, um the idea is to connect
this to the ArcGI benchmark um and that
kind of thing. So, you know, that
benchmark has a partition like a yeah uh
a solvability uh association. So, we
have some next steps and this is pretty
much the end of my presentation. I ran a
few seconds over, but yeah, if you're
interested, talk to me later.
[Music]